the role of killmonger took a serious
toll on star michael b jordan
after gaining mainstream attention
through films like the heart-wrenching
2013 biographical drama
food fail station the 2015 sports drama
creed
and the 2015 reboot of fantastic four
jordan joined the marvel cinematic
universe the actor reunited with his
fruitvale station and creed director
ryan coogler
for 2018 super smash hit black panther
in which jordan played eric killmonger
stevens aka killmonger
in black panther killmonger is more than
just a run-of-the-mill baddie who wants
to take down the hero
he has a connection to chadwick
boseman's king t'challa and an
emotionally driven purpose for wanting
to overthrow him as the leader
of wakanda the film reveals that
killmonger's birth name is anjadaka
and that he's a cousin of king t'challa
after t'challa's father the then king of
wakanda tachaka
and the wakandan statesman zuri
confronts killmonger's father and jobu
about his plans to reveal wakanda's
technology to the rest of the world
to charka kills and jobu in order to
perpetuate elijah and jobu simply
disappeared while undercover
tachaka and zuri leave and jobu's son
behind and fly back to wakanda
that child grows up to be killmonger who
eventually becomes a black ops soldier
for the us military
before partnering with ulysses claw a
black market arms dealer with access to
wakandan technology
it's a long way to the throne but
killmonger's plan finally ends with a
battle against t'challa that mirrors the
one between their fathers
after his defeat killmonger chooses to
die as a free man
rather than be held as a prisoner for
the rest of his life
just bury me in the ocean with my
ancestors that jump from the ships
because they knew death was better than
bondage
certainly killmonger is a character
whose roots are planted in pain and
trauma
for jordan it was difficult to remain in
that headspace for an extended period of
time
in a november 2018 interview on the bill
simmons podcast
jordan opened up to the radio host about
the mental weight he was left with after
portraying killmonger
it was one of those things that i didn't
know what was going on i never wasn't a
character for that long of a period of
time and never was i guess that dark
that lonely that painful so coming out
of it i thought
oh yeah business as usual i can just go
back home
i'll cut my hair off and everything will
be back to normal however that plan
didn't exactly pan out
jordan found it more difficult than he
had anticipated to fully step away from
killmonger according to comicbook.com
the actor needed a month of time in
therapy sessions to fully close the door
on the black panther villain
jordan explained i found myself kind of
in the routine of being isolated and
went out of my way to make sure i was by
myself
and didn't say too much more than the
usual once i got finished wrapping the
movie
it took me some time to talk through how
i was feeling and why i was feeling so
sad and like a little bit depressed
ultimately jordan said that reconnecting
with friends and loved ones and talking
things out helped him get back to normal
killmonger might have been a difficult
role for jordan but it also further
helped skyrocket him to superstar him
the same year black panther hit the big
screen jordan booked two starring roles
in an adaptation of fahrenheit 451
and in creed 2. in 2019 he headlined
just mercy
a true story about systemic problems in
the criminal justice system
jordan is also moving behind the camera
and producing new shows
including netflix's superhero origin
story raising dion
in which he coasts out as a scientist
named mark warren while the movie
industry remains more or less on hold as
of the making of this video
jordan has some exciting projects lined
up nonetheless beyond his late 2020
release without remorse he's set to team
up with coogler once again for wrong
answer
a film about cheating scandals in
atlanta's public schools
additionally jordan is set to star in a
new remake of the thomas crown affair
among other more secretive projects if
you want to relive jordan's journey as
killmonger black panther is streaming on
disney plus
now check out one of our newest videos
right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one